it's been about a month since the
shocking news of you your father's death
i know he was ill for a while but it
still was shocking
how you doing i'm awful it's terrible
yeah yeah uh every day man uh
some days are better than others but
overall it's like
you know i think the pain is still there
always but you just kind of figure out
how to carry it a bit better as time
goes on
but it's always going to hurt do you
think that you and your dad had such a
close
relationship because you had that
musical bond i mean you could speak your
father's language
that's the gift and the curse of it uh
you know is that
you know we had such a close connection
um
and now for the rest of my life there's
no way i'll never be able to think about
him no matter what i do
um which is good but it also it hurts a
lot this song that you wrote for your
father i think it's beautiful i think
people will be very moved by this
thank you and you were writing it as
your father was dying i recorded a a
bunch of songs
and i have the stuff i want to use for
for the album
um but there's like
a bunch of other ideas that are kind of
just waiting there to be finished
and distance was one of those and when
this happened it was like
let's finish it and let's have that be
the first song out
and put it put it out for dad yeah i
love the song and i was so glad i loved
it because i've never heard anything
from you solo and i went oh wolfgang's
coming on
and what if the song blows you know and
it doesn't move me well i put it on
i watched it ten times first of all you
have these great home videos
of you and your dad when you're sitting
at the piano on your dad's lap and he's
playing the piano he [ __ ] lost it
it is so beautiful the song is one thing
but
it's very important to watch the video
with it um you know
um but yeah it's funny that you
mentioned
like what if it sucked uh yeah my dad
and i would joke around
like even as recently as a couple months
ago he would be like
hey pop wouldn't like what would you do
if all my music really sucked like if
you hated it like what would you have
what would you do wouldn't that suck
he would laugh and he said impossible